I'm Carlos Valdez and I'm May Whitman we
are chilling on the setup up here
[Music]
pictures up
up here is about two people it's about
Lindsay and Miguel when we meet Lindsay
she's in a life that she doesn't
actually want I'm leaving you and she
ends up throwing everything away and
moving to New York City to start over
again she wants to bring her Focus back
to her own self as opposed to trying to
be this version of what she's supposed
to be I love it Miguel is a New York
native he's coming off of a breakup I
think Miguel has a lot of armor off
you're gonna be okay I can handle it I
think that what really sets this show
apart is that each of our characters is
haunted by these voices from their past
it's time to give up you're weak you're
pathetic you're perfect just please shut
up I think it's a story about breaking
free from all of the critical voices
that have taken a hold of you I knew she
was trouble you don't need her mama's
here
okay that's creepy
can two people ever really know one
another or are we all just stuck in our
heads what are you thinking about
nothing
it felt like the perfect thing to
dramatize and the perfect thing to
musicalize and what if we saw the
musicals that were in their heads at the
same time
to really get someone to know
it takes like true professionals to be
brilliantly funny and smart what Stephen
Levinson did with the writing is the
mark of a true genius the thing that
really stands out to me about up here is
the incredible music that Bobby and
Kristen have written which I think is
just extraordinary it's a really joyful
show and a really joyful world and the
more I see the cuts the more I realize
that working with Tommy kale has been a
master class we all came together and
had a like glorious collaboration it's
pretty impressive you're my special
little man and don't you forget it
it has enormous heart and big feelings
it's a musical it's a comedy it's a
story of coming of age there's a theme
Here of loving yourself and allowing
yourself to be loved all those voices
they don't see what I do this is a show
that is funny and strange but also has a
real kind of joyfulness
it's gonna be fun I'll catch you on the
other side
foreign
[Music]